some months ago after the first wave
we were already complacently deeming
ourselves
pandemic world champions and now
it's the opposite we are practically
vying to outdo one another in doom and
gloom
does everything really have to be a
superlative in germany
as goethe put it now shouting in triumph
now sunk in despair
we're not pandemic world champions but
we're not an utter failure
no we are the federal republic of
germany we may often have our doubts
but there's plenty we're capable of and
it's our capabilities not our doubts
which matter now
german president frank walter steinmeier
is sent to make a rare appeal to the
nation
this easter weekend amid growing
frustration with the pandemic
infections are once again surging in the
country with
more than 18 000 new daily cases
in a pre-recorded address which will air
on saturday evening
steinmeier will ask germans to overcome
what he calls
a crisis of trust in the government
the pandemic has held up a mirror to our
country
reflecting our compulsion to lay down
rules for everything
our fear of taking risks the shunting
back and forth of responsibility
how can we change that and how can we
make our institutions more resilient
we will have to address that at the
moment however we are in the midst of
the third wave
and it will take all of our strength all
of us together
to overcome it dw
chief political analyst melinda crane
joins us now
to put the german president's remarks
into a bit of context for
us hello to you melinda i'd like to um
go right to what he just said in that
clip we played about germany facing
itself in a mirror
reflecting on this compulsion to lay
down rules for everything a fear of
taking risks
um shunting back and forth from
responsibility
what is the president driving at
well he's essentially driving at what is
perceived by many people here in germany
as a constant back and forth course
of covet pandemic management so
we have the minister presidents of the
federal government
meeting at regular intervals and then
issuing pronouncements and then often a
couple of weeks later appearing to take
back those pronouncements or to modify
them
or different federal states disagreeing
with one another
about how to proceed and in fact the
german constitution
vests primary health policy
responsibility
in the federal states but the fact
is that there's been a lot of tussling
between them and the federal government
about whether
to tighten restrictions loosen
restrictions
and many citizens have the sense that
leadership
is missing and therefore that is why the
president
uh issued what is a pretty uh clear
warning or even a scolding
to politicians coupled with concern
about as you said a crisis of trust
we have another short clip from these
pre-recorded remarks let's have a quick
listen
we must all pull together my fellow
germans we must give it everything we've
got
there's no use merely being outraged
about others or about our leaders
rather than constantly pointing out what
doesn't work we should point out that
things do work when everyone does their
bit
that is what i'm talking about when i
talk about trust
because ultimately trusting in a
democracy means nothing other than
trusting
in ourselves
all right melinda so you said uh just
before
it's clear that steinmeier is addressing
at least partly
german politicians in this clip we just
heard he's talking a lot about
trust and also urging germans not just
to focus on what's going wrong
with the pandemic response what is his
underlying
message here and who is it targeted at
well it's essentially targeted uh at uh
both
uh german citizens uh but also at
uh german politics uh essentially
saying look easter is a time for hope
and there is every reason to be hopeful
the vaccine rollout is now gathering
speed many people will have the
opportunity to be
vaccinated but essentially he's saying
for them to
avail themselves of that opportunity
they need
to trust trust in the vaccines trust in
the judgment
of political leaders and therefore he's
essentially melding these two
hope and trust and it's crucial to know
the german president
doesn't set policy himself he's
essentially the moral compass of the
nation and that's why he's speaking
to these overriding themes hope and
trust
dw's chief political analyst melinda
crane thank you so much